to the rest of the day's news in the
un's top court has rejected kenya's
claims in a maritime border dispute in
the indian ocean somalia filed the
lawsuit with the international court of
justice in the hague after kenya awarded
exploration riots in waters somalia says
are within its boundary the disputed 100
square kilometer area has been
identified as potentially rich in oil
and gas kenya has already said it will
not recognize the court's ruling for
more on this let's bring in malcolm webb
who's been covering the story for us in
nairobi hello there malcolm tell us more
about the court's ruling which was
largely in favor of somalia
well the international court of justice
ruling was largely in favor of somalia
although one of kenya's requests was
accepted it has a slither of the
disputed
maritime territory but most of it goes
to somalia and as you said it's widely
believed to be rich in oil and gas
deposits
it's also important to understand that
rich natural resource wealth in this
region
almost always leads to a great deal of
personal wealth for people in positions
of power these are two countries where
corruption is widespread uh and also uh
it is also widely understood that the
people in both countries who had their
eye on these oil and gas reserves are
also
have international oil companies and
other partners
behind them but the court has ruled for
now that most of this
this maritime territory does indeed
go to somalia
in only a little bit of what was
disputed is going to kenya
thank you for that update malcolm webb
there for us live in nairobi appreciate
your time
a reminder now of the competing claims
between the two countries at stake his
control of one hundred thousand square
kilometer stretch of the indian ocean
with prospects of vast oil and gas
deposits as we heard
kenya says its maritime border should be
drawn in a straight line east parallel
to the line of latitude somalia however
says it should be expanded further south
as an extension of its land border the
dispute has further strained relations
between the neighbours let's bring in
now
an expert on maritime law and
international law his name is george
wacko yeah hello there george thanks for
joining us what impact is this ruling
going to have on somalia and kenya
particularly given how rich these deep
waters may be with oil and gas
well uh first of all thank you very much
for inviting me on this
program
the impact is great the impact is great
given the fact that
somalia has been given a lot larger
chunk of land
which means that it's going to reduce
kenya
into a landlocked country even if it
will have a small
passage you will not have an exclusive
enjoyment of
an exclusive economic zone which means
that
the kenyan
economic future
in the sea in the blue
chip economics is going to be
reduced to some extent secondly
the impact also has got far reaching
consequences
whereby both parties now have to find
out a solution
of federation whether they they want to
renegotiate
deals separately from the ruling whether
they want to have some kind of an accord
uh or whether kenya has got in a way
leverage of appealing which i don't see
because they walked out of the court we
don't know
george
while these rulings by the world court
are final
is there any way of enforcement
yes there are so many mechanisms of
enforcement
and number one
[Music]
this is we are dealing with
international law and we are dealing
with the international court of final
jurisdiction
and you are also dealing with the court
of
compulsory compulsory jurisdiction which
is actually still which stems its powers
from the united nations
where the guiding
master in this case is the united
nations security council therefore
if it comes to
enforcement yes there are ways in which
somalia can choose to reinforce not
necessarily by force
but it can go into a negotiated
solution by asking kenya to cooperate or
the united nations to come in or this
purpose to come in or other partners to
come in and have
a way out of the whole situation by
having a negotiated settlement but if
kenya
tries for attempts to use force
then that can escalate into war which is
not necessary
at the moment so kenya is also at
a precarious
position or vicarious position where it
can also opt to negotiate with somalia
because these two countries are brothers
and they're always dependent on each
other given the fact that we have a
cross section
of for
us it is citizens who are trading who
have been trading and we also have
somalis who live in kenya born in kenya
we have somalis who live in
somalia born and raised in somalia so
they should look out for a negotiated
settlement
it doesn't sound though that kenya will
cooperate you know with the attempts to
boycott the public hearings and the like
i mean how confident are you that they
will cooperate
they may not cooperate because the day
before yesterday
some of the officials pared in the army
when they were issuing a press
conference which in itself was a
violation of international law
which actually violated the articles of
war
which may lead
the warnings that the department
secretary was saying that they are ready
at any time and parading some of the
senior cadre of military
would actually suggest that we are ready
for war and in which case somalia could
use that
clause in the u.n i think it should be
article 39 or 41
of preemptation clause to declare one
king
so that to me was not necessary it
wasn't necessary to parade
the army and issue such declaratory
statements before the verdict
that means they were undermining the
court's jurisdiction they ought to have
waited for the outcome of the case
well there are plenty of moving parts to
this story watch this space thank you
for your insights george
jacoya is an expert on maritime and
international law thank you
thank you very much